l'environnement précisément avec un
tableau de sézanne au coeur d'une
controverse dans les yvelines un projet
immobilier pourrait dénaturer un paysage
immortalisé par le peintre une bataille
qui relancent par ailleurs le débat sur
les nouvelles constructions autour de
paris daniel wolfromm hervé photo une
opération immobilière prévu en août
cette colline la chose a de quoi faire
sortir de ses gonds et de sa
gentilhommière ce monsieur ardents
défenseurs de ces lieux fréquentés il ya
un siècle par quelques ce beat et de la
littérature et des arts
voici l'une des trois photos prises par
emile zola sur ce site en face de nous
les quinze maisons vont se découper ici
en crête sur un paysage devenue célèbre
puisque paul cézanne lapin à trois
reprises
voici l'une de ses toiles et les maisons
voient se trouvait donc hall sommet de
ce coteau les bords de seine ses coteaux
boisés ses vieilles demeures
une partie du site est protégé mais
jusqu'où ya encore des arbres bien
entendu le maire prétend même qu'il va
renforcer la lisière
mais c'est tout à fait illusoire le
maire grandit donc le coteau avec son
conseil municipal et garantit que les
maisons de défigureront pas le paysage
peint par cézanne grâce à ces mesures
c'est à dire les renforcements paysages
et les arbres de haute tige avec les
arbustes caducs
la zone de la constructibilité de 30
mètres la hauteur des faîtages 1,8 m le
sens des pentes de toit parallèle aux
coteaux de manière à ce qu effectivement
il n'y a aucun pignon qui puisse être
visible des milliers de sites sont
inscrits au patrimoine pour leur intérêt
écologique ou paysager difficile
cependant d'appliquer cette loi aux
portes de paris
est ce que la france doit être partout
dans toutes les circonstances
un conservatoire à l'identique de sites
qui ont présenté un intérêt à un moment
ou à un autre
je suis pas sûr que la réponse soit
partout systématiquement oui
sur les coteaux de cesana mais dans la
querelle entre les associations et la
mairie dure depuis des années
le terrain à bâtir lui est toujours en
jachère pour combien de temps encore